welcome to another video with my lovely
murse mm-hmm you have completely planned
out this video yeah so why don't you
take over and explain what's gonna
happen well I bought you for office oh
my god
the cliche girlfriend dresses boy right
thanks fine you forced me to do this
you held me at gunpoint my old
girlfriend no I'm actually excited
because I think you have a good eye for
my style mm-hmm it's a popular type of
video right now where the boyfriend
dresses girlfriend or guy for dresses I
usually do it together like I do you do
me but in this case you didn't want to
bother for a fix
wait for three it was really challenging
because I know your style and I couldn't
just ball you for others that I know you
wear at all time but I wanted to get
something that it's yourself go with it
twist to like there is a more casual one
there is a sporty one there is a more
luxury Oh an experimental one experiment
yeah I don't know how you're gonna feel
about that one but we're gonna begin
weed one that it's fairly safe are you
ready I'm really nervous
also if you want to buy if you don't
want to look like a garbage tragic trash
can you can buy my merch as well please
yeah yeah it doesn't say
so these shall we say you can't go to
crazy lazy well it's all green oh I like
green green is in now the moss color you
like it I like it
we got the first one is a duty I like it
three older sighs yeah oh that's cool
that's really cool Doh I like it a lot
it reminds me of my others white shirt
but I like it it's okay I like this one
a lot
good job rice yeah okay yeah you got an
A
oh you like cuz I never saw you wear
caps my daddy my camera's so cool and
look at all the smiley face let's do
this is gonna look cool together I like
I'm all about matching matching right
now these I mean no I'm not I like it
that's why I'm well - laughs close so
they have like tiny little smiley faces
on them yeah
the problem now is that if I because I
wanna wear is and whenever I'm gonna
wear it oh you go from bet you the one
yeah someone
[Music]
but I'm thinking that you will cut them
up a bit
they aren't very big okay you didn't
expect them to be that baggy are you
smaller than I thought
medium I do look very small you should
turn this way
third the right way sighs okay but I
think it's just a thing yeah
so I'm not sure if these will actually
go that well together together yeah I
like the vigil me before that you know
but the wood is good yeah that is really
cool and the Pens I think will look cool
once I make them slimmer Thanks
well done marks here the first outfit is
completed so this is experimental 100 we
need to say let's go experiment
reclaimed bindi I like that Brenda okay
so ethical brandy to tell that's why do
need sauce that's why I need more sucks
huh
a larger sharks mark yeah oh yeah okay
why you got a problem with my glass
front okay these happen
starts up yes I like it cool
you like yeah I like it I wasn't sure if
you were gonna like I liked it oh do you
know my size do you know that you think
you're way bigger this is just a medium
this is a medium has never failed me me
t that's a meaning to it
everything I bought everything meet you
so you're probably small just be aware
of it
okay well I the things we shirts is I
like them on me anyway they're to my
Decorah well you're leaving this one
open so then the cool pics do we have
some of the effort problem
oh wow it matches all the way huh for
their swift taxi kindness that's nice
I can always appreciate yeah yeah you
gotta mix comfy with fashion yes I'm
really scared about these shoes now I
have a very principled thing with shoes
I can only have one pair a maximum - all
these are cool actually but white shoes
are dangerous black and white
I've had shoes like this and they just
go out oh that would look cool yeah
should we these outfit any socks with
the black and white yeah all right you
guys copied my knees up though and
welcome to your life sure so you can see
them okay okay this has potential yeah
now let me just transform
[Music]
it's cool I'll give you that I just
don't leave me anything that's it man
yeah I'll keep the t-shirt okay
I feel like another person I feel like
um anyway let's oh all right okay kids
you wanna yeah I don't want to judge
before I seen it this black one what
this bo genius okay we're going oh gee
guys oh my god
this is K was that it okay
I do like it very nice you know they
she's gonna love it yeah mmm comfortable
just like I'm wearing nothing at all do
you like it or thanks phone yeah yeah
you look good you like it dude it looks
nice I guess I didn't see you looking
this night on me you know but you know
as my mom would always say anything fits
a beauty
[Music]
you're doing great Marcia let me just
tell you this one well I like it on me
you know yeah what can I say I'm a
handsome beautiful man mm-hmm
with an even more hands beautiful letter
girlfriend thank you look how beautiful
she go round of applause I don't know I
never seemed ready for but it's like oh
it's Japanese bread yes maybe Japan good
I love it now cave it it's done I like
this this is edgy and overpriced just
like I like it never seen something like
this is my favorite piece so far okay
we'll see if it's ten sizes too big hug
medium size medium sex Oh No you've got
me jeans weird heart gay jeans my
favorite thing to wear in the whole work
something about this type of jeans that
I'm like yeah
but we'll try it out you know maybe it's
good okay beauty
oh love that but the pants doesn't
really go with it they I don't like
pants but I realize whether a lot done
it's short it fits so nicely mm-hmm I
just don't like these type of jeans
oh you truck stop
first of all might say I'm round of
applause you did thank you I'm so proud
of you why should it just gotta you
might see sweatshirt you could have
played it simple but you know what you
did you did you try and you know why
ain't you trying I really like first
outfit I think it's cool
the thing that makes it uncool how bad
is my I came up with my own idea to wear
something like that then then the
confidence of pulling that after off
kind of makes it work but the fact that
someone else gave it to me makes it kind
of like you don't have to wait to get it
right I really like the shirt I do I
might you know I might wear okay all
right I might just well I think the
pants will look nicer we'd like a tech
pin oh sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry the
first outfit I thought this was the
first outfit I'm sorry I'm sorry about
this one I got confused oh okay yeah
I'll find a way to wear any of these
either even me yeah they were
comfortable so the first one you did
great mm-hmm
second one was to what I was talking
maybe it's more summery like yeah yeah
it's rotten season I'll wear it next
season for sure for sure you played it
safe from the third outfit which I can
appreciate because I've 100% wear this
sweatpants is just the greatest gift to
God so you don't mind it's all black no
no I think the pants will look cool when
stuff okay don't sweat her you didn't
get man
and it's probably some really cool brand
that I don't know about I feel a bit old
yeah we got a secret handshake don't
copy it remember to check out my
meatballs shirt at 1:00 it's selling
like a god Church well leave a like if
you enjoyed and maybe we'll do what I
want to do one for you I want to do it I
do want to do one for you and I think
you'll feel how it great is to be given
a gift I'm sure Ellie look do you think
you can just pour out it would see you
next time till then
[Music]